Speaker 1: OK, let's talk about a few other
things that happened this weekend, some of
them are 9/11 related.
You know, Rudy Giuliani was the mayor of New
York City when 9/11 happened.
And there is certainly debate about the degree
to which Rudy Giuliani handled 9/11 properly.
But there is no question that he was experiencing
a very solid and healthy approval rating at
the time.
He was seen colloquially as America's mayor.
And I'm not saying I agree with him on all
policy, but he had a high approval rating
and was relatively well respected.
That has gone into the toilet over the years
as he has gotten more and more involved with
Donald Trump and then really embarrassed himself
regularly with all of the voter fraud stuff
and appearing on television seemingly drunk
multiple times, a charge which he has denied.
But he's continued holding this annual 9/11
dinner.
The 9/11 dinner this past weekend went completely
off the rails with Rudy Giuliani showing up
apparently so drunk that he was making no
sense and slurring some things he might do
not drunk.
Also, we're not making fun of alcoholism.
We're merely just, again, stating the fact
that this is a guy who's been put in positions
of significant power and responsibility.
And he may not be he may be lacking the capacity
for it, partially because of what seems to
be a drinking problem.
Many reports about they would try to keep
Rudy off of nighttime television because it
was more likely he would be drunk and so on
and so forth.
And we're going to look at a couple of clips.
And it just just the degree to which this
guy has fallen from grace is insane.
Business Insider reporting video captures
Rudy Giuliani's rambling speech at a 9/11
dinner in which he impersonated Queen Elizabeth.
The second, yeah, Rudy gave a rambling speech
at his annual dinner.
The former mayor impersonated Queen Elizabeth,
said he's never socialized with disgraced
Prince Andrew.
Giuliani also described how he wanted to grab
General Mark Moelis, awarded stars and shove
it down his throat.
Let's just get right into the video clips,
OK?
This is this is Rudie.
This was broadcast on Real America's Voice.
It's all wacky.
Speaker 2: Tony Blinken or Miley.
How house I a general choose.
The other day he said that the Bagram Air
Force Base is not strategically important.
Speaker 1: I want to strategically grab this.
Speaker 2: What are you, five stars, 10 stars,
12 stars?
Yes.
So many stars that are coming up to his ears.
I wanted to grab his stars, shove it down
his throat and say it 400 miles from China
at whole world.
China is going to be our enemies for the next
40 years.
You have an air base 400 miles from them and
you're giving it up.
Idiot, right.
What?
Speaker 1: I like the one guy yelling right
in the audience, how
Speaker 2: is wrong with you?
Who pays you price?
That is crazy.
I don't know how I should get into this.
What Biden did in the last two weeks is freaking
insane.
It cannot be explained.
Yeah, well, 20 years ago, I did my job for
the country.
I'm very proud of it, but I did it because
of them.
Bernie demonstrated to you I was so happy
he did it.
Speaker 1: This is it is sad more than anything,
right?
Speaker 2: You can't show everybody, right?
You can't show.
Look, every one of them would like to show
you the ten people that supported them.
Right.
Ashfall.
To do it on your own.
How many people did you have helping you?
I had Danny.
I had Tony.
Hi, Howard.
I had Joe.
Speaker 1: And Bill was in the mailroom
Speaker 2: and a lot of people thought where
Tony and that was me.
Speaker 1: Really, really strange stuff.
And then eventually he went into his Queen
Elizabeth impression.
And it, if you can imagine it got even more
weird.
Speaker 2: She said you could do a wonderful
job on September 11 and therefore I'm making
you an honorary knight commander of the royal
something.
Rather, I turned down a knighthood because
if you took a knighthood, you had to lose
your citizenship.
I know Prince Andrew is very questionable
now.
I never went out with him.
Never, never, never had a drink with him.
Never was with a woman or a young girl with
him.
Whoa.
What?
Speaker 1: Making a lot of denials unprovoked,
aren't you, Rudy?
Speaker 2: One time I met him in my office
and one time when we had the party.
Right, Bernie, you were there.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
OK, anyway, so Rudy Giuliani really just an
embarrassing fall from grace.
Rudy Giuliani recently said he doesn't think
he's ever done an interview drunk.
Doesn't think.
But he did say I drink normally like scotch.
I drink scotch.
He also said I'm not an alcoholic.
I'm a functioning.
I probably function more effectively than
90 percent of the population, and whether
that's a Freudian slip where what he's saying
is he's a functioning alcoholic or just that
he functions really well, not really clear,
but just a very sad state of affairs for Rudy
Giuliani.
I think it's time now with the 20th anniversary
to retire these 9/11 annual dinners.
They've gotten just a little bit too off the
rails.
And if we end up hearing anything about Rudy
and Prince Andrew, certainly that would be
interesting.
Given is completely out of the blue denial
there